Jamal just two years ago this time you
were barely able to walk but you vowed
to come back
you vowed to come back even better than
you were before can you describe to me
what this this Championship Journey has
been like
this amazing feeling you know I love
sweating tears to get back to this point
um
everybody on my teammate here everybody
on the floor believe me believe me to
get back to myself and uh
you know we proved a lot of doubters
wrong and
I mean look at this
I appreciate it
you've said that had you not gotten hurt
you think you guys would have been here
sooner than this was it worth the wait
oh yeah I mean I learned a lot about
myself just being up for two post
Seasons
um just grinding you know having so many
things go through my head
watching my team you know go through the
ups and downs and uh just to see us
healthy know what we can do we have the
belief from the get-go you guys had the
belief in the get-go
it's full circle so it's just great to
see it through my dad right there
yeah pops
he helped me he believed from the start
he got me to where I am today and uh
it's just a blessing you know it's not
me it's it's God willing so I appreciate
him giving me the strength thank you
Jamal thank you one more